ça on va pouvoir entre a créé un peu
objectif remobilisation des troupes avec
ses 48 % du premier tour alain suguenot
aborde le 2nd serein mais vigilant
il souhaite faire élire conseiller un
maximum de ses colistiers et pour y
parvenir il doit éviter que certains de
ces électeurs pensent que c'est déjà
gagné et s'abstiennent souvent les gens
très pauvres les gens qui nous
soutiennent le débat oui mais j'ai pas
pu porter l'été raison ou dix ans
effectivement ben non ça va bien se
passer non ça se passe jamais c'est
comme en matière sportive donc vous
n'êtes pas passé la ligne d'arrivée
l'élection s'il n'ya pas démocratie ça
sert à rien de voter si on vote c'est
parce qu'il ya toujours bien sûr la
possibilité de gagner ou faire
je fais partie des candidats potentiels
qui disent après tout est toujours à bhl
une élection n'est jamais gagnée
d'avancé mais ma deuxième tour s'avère
très court mais dense et de toute
manière tout ce qui est fait après le 28
juin ça sert à rien quoi ses avants eric
mono n'a récolté qu'un peu plus de 28%
des suffrages le 15 mars dernier
il a bien tenté de négocier avec la
liste de gauche arrivée troisième mais
l'opération a échoué après cinq jours de
discussions le candidat soutenu par la
république en marge de temps encore
croire en ses chances de ravir le
fauteuil de maire même s'il sait
qu'elles sont très minces on a mille 600
électeurs et c'est le message que je
veux faire passer à à tous les beaunois
qui ont envie de changement
si chaque électeur emmène un électeur
qui n'est pas allé voter on en connaît
tous un ou deux c'est gagné c'est gagné
alain suguenot il a fait le plein carole
bernard en se maintenant elle fera un
score déplorable parce que il va y avoir
un vote utile
je veux dire c'est karl bernard en ce
sens en décidant de se présenter elle se
fait l'allié objectif d'1 1 suguenot
alliés d'alain suguenot
pas sûr que la candidate écologiste
apprécié la formule avec ses colistiers
et carole bernard tente de faire exister
la gauche dans cette élection si elle a
réussi à unir ses différentes
composantes
elle n'a obtenu que 12 points 4 % au
premier tour j'étais assez déçu des
résultats du premier tour mais bon c'est
vrai que il y avait quand même 7
cette abstention record de 57 %
c'est-à-dire 12% de plus qu'en 2014 qui
a quand même
déséquilibré les votes qui aurait dû
avoir lieu
donc je j'aimerais qu'on soit au moins
trois ou quatre conseillers municipaux
de not least à siéger pour pouvoir faire
avancer nos idées
éliminée dès le premier tour le
rassemblement national ne donne pas de
consigne de vote
mario barravecchia appelle lui à faire
barrage au maire sortant